Lucas is writing in how can I promote
quality health and home care products
and increase the awareness my customer
base I think um yeah back to your point
it is almost like um the products I
think you've gotta look for what is she
trying to solve and I think things like
health care products home care products
there's obviously a massive market with
us in Canada usl globally um but but it
really is about what does it give the
people who are going to use those
clothes how does it make their lives
better how does it meet their health
better and appealing to them and then I
don't know if again back to Evan point
if you could find say some of your
buddies who's a bit of a kind of leader
or a doctor or someone who's an industry
trusted advisor to start talk about the
issues and and then you create the
issues and you come in and your products
one of the solutions around that so I
think it's more about and I just look at
some of our cousins and what gem has
done with kind of the massive health
food business business of like five
million dollars turnover nothing few
years ago cells across 33 countries she
had some kind of focus just on product
sales she's really focused on beautiful
product delicious products free of
chemicals and and there's a lot of
people like all of us probably on this
um on this plan we're actually yeah we
with we buy that because he's helping us
to eat well be healthy and have a more
kind of holistic you of ourselves is a
you know your competitive advantage is
your story your values why are you doing
this in most markets you have it's a
commodity right like health care and
home care products there's tons of it so
there's there might be some product
differentiation but the way to stand out
is your story right make me feel
something that's as an entrepreneur it's
riskier to go with you because you're
the you're the newer kid on the block
why would I go with an entrepreneur when
I can buy from a safe established
company it's because of the story
because of the values that you have as
example some guy who called in had a
lawn care service right so he
and took care of your flowers all that
stuff and I said well you know why
should I that's a hard business right
like I could go to my next door neighbor
who's got a high school kid and say hey
here's 15 bucks mow the lawn right so
how are you going to compete when you're
charging three times that much and that
was his challenge and I said well why do
you why did you start this business
because when I was young I spent hours
every week out there with my mom and we
you know move belong together and we did
all the potting the flowers and we did
all the landscaping together and I
started this business because it you
know reminds me of her it's paying
tribute to her and I treat everybody's
lon like it's my mother's line and right
there like you feel the passion in his
voice and you know it's not just a
marketing thing I would pay that guy two
or three times as much then the high
school kid down the street because I
feel like he cares more than the other
person and then he's going to do a good
job on my lawn right and so that's what
you need to do for your business to
write why do you care so much about home
and health care products why is it
important why are you starting this
thing you know if you can tap into that
and for all entrepreneurs watching right
you tap into that story and you share it
make me feel something on an emotional
level and that's going to attract the
right customers to you